bill thank you for that
well as you can imagine that's not the
only project in the works as las vegas
continues to grow new casinos and
entertainment venues are popping up left
and right so let's take a trip around
town to see what's on the horizon
about 2.7 million people called southern
nevada home last year and that number is
expected to rise to 3.4 million by the
year 2060 according to a study by unlv
as more residents move to the desert so
are new venues
a state-of-the-art facility is being
built right now that is hoping to take
entertainment to a digital future the
msg sphere which is located behind the
venetian will be the largest spherical
structure in the world
a few blocks away this 67-story hotel
and casino is hoping to change the las
vegas skyline the fountain blue already
establishing its white logo across the
hotel tower while renderings of the
property which open late next year shows
upscale ballroom areas
growth is not only happening along the
strip durango casino and resort is
stationed casino's newest property
already underway along the 215 and
durango road all expected to be
completed late next year second and 15
jalen henderson completes it the 84
million dollar loan center arena
recently hosted their first event in
henderson and became home to the
valley's first indoor football team the
vegas nighthawks and the henderson
silver knights minor league hockey team
well another project still in
development south of the strip is the
brightline rail station for a high-speed
train that would connect las vegas to
victorville now the company says
it's expected to be built in the next
few years so stay tuned
what do you think with all the events
coming to town do we need another arena
share your thoughts on our eight news
now twitter poll so far the majority say
no we will check in on the results again
at five o'clock